-Our first guest tonight i
a comedian, activist,
and six-time number-one
"New York Times"
best-selling author.
Her latest special,
"Chelsea Handler: Evolution,
is available to stream
on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-Which brings me
to the strong and deep
sexual feelings
that I have developed
for Andrew Cuomo.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, I know we all feel it.
A lot of women are feeling it.
When he came on the scene,
he looked like
the Incredible Hulk also.
You know,
that big Italian gorilla.
It's like, "Put on your mask."
I'm like, "Oh, I'll
put my mask on.
Oh, yeah, I will.
I'll put on my mask."
He's the kind of [Bleep]
that I will do [Bleep] for
And you know he's an [Bleep]
and that's
what I like about him.
Like, an old-fashioned
[Bleep] --
somebody who's gonna tell me
to sit down and shut up.
I want him to flatten my curve
and then I want to
flatten his curve.
[ Laughter ]
And then I want us
to apex together.
-Please welcome back to the show
our good friend Chelsea Handler.
How are you, Chelsea?
-Hi, Seth.
-It is so lovely to see yo
braving the elements.
You're in Canada.
-I am.
I'm Canadian now, I think.
I'm hoping to become Canadian.
I actually came home --
I was skiing all morning,
and I came home
to try and do my hair for you.
And then I just realized
it was futile.
So I decided, "Screw it."
You don't give a [Bleep].
I don't either.
-I think you found
a perfect solution,
because this is
an excellent look for you.
You are a fairly avid skier.
Is that a fair assessment?
-Yes. I'm in Whistler, Canada.
I'm working in Canada,
so I can combine
my two favorite things --
um, Canada and cannabis.
-[ Laughs ]
That's a nice combo.
You have jokes --
maybe there was
more truth to it than that -
about maybe moving to Canada
one of these days.
Now that you're spending
some time there,
is that something
you would consider?
-Well, I did buy a house
in Canada --
in Whistler, specifically --
right before the election,
because I was, like -- you know,
I was a little bit scared
of what could possibly happen.
But now I just have
this great place,
and I have this gig
up here in Canada.
So I'm like, "Oh, I guess
I'll just move in
to my new pad --
my new ski pad."
So, I'm, like, living alone.
It's like my first
big-girl apartment.
I'm all by myself.
I had to quarantine
for two weeks with my dog.
So my house smells
like dog urine and cannabis.
-You mentioned
you're there by yourself.
You've been very honest
over the years,
in your books and stand-up
about the fact
that you're fairly pampere
and have had
a pretty supportive staff.
How did you do,
setting up a house by yourself
-[ Chuckles ]
It's not --
I mean, I've thrown
my back out twice.
I tried to roll out a carpet
I've tried to cook
several items, you know?
And nothing's edible.
I did learn
how to bake a chicken.
So that's something.
-That is something.
-But I want to be
more self-sufficient.
So, like, I'm
trying really hard,
but it's embarrassing,
'cause I'm like 45
and I can't do basic stuff
-[ Chuckles ]
The same is true of me,
and I've got
a couple years on you.
Hey, here's Bert and Bernice
You mentioned your two dogs.
Do I have their names right?
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
Yeah, that's them.
-How are they behaving?
Are they enjoying
their time with you?
-They are.
Well, the cleaning lady
is really the top dog
at my house in L.A.
My dogs really prefer her.
Her name is Mabel.
They prefer her over me,
so them saying goodbye
was very traumatic
for my big dog, Bert,
'cause she really likes
to egg it on.
She likes
that they like her more.
She's got that over me.
But when they were saying
goodbye at the airport,
it was really ridiculous -
like, open-mouth kissing.
And the more she does that -
like, she's literally
opening her mouth
and kissing my dog,
and he's also --
his mouth is also open.
And I'm watching that
like, "How is this okay?"
And then,
the more she does that,
the more depressed Bert is
when she's gone.
We get on the plane, and
he's just like this.
-[ Chuckles ]
-So it's rough.
-So, if Bert wanted
to open-mouth kiss you,
would you push him away?
Well, no.
That's a great question, Seth.
And thanks for asking it.
-Yeah.
-I think that if Bert
wanted to kiss me,
I would be so delighted
that I would --
No, I don't think I would
open-mouth kiss him,
because I know what kind o
food I'm feeding him,
and I don't want that
in my mouth.
-I recently --
Over the holidays,
I saw my parents' dogs.
And I did some open-mouth
kissing with them.
And basically, my wife
then demanded,
like, quarantine for that --
that I had done that.
-[ Laughs ]
There's a lot of things
we're finding out
that you should be
quarantining for and from.
-So, I know it's difficult
to, obviously, date
during a pandemic.
And from the clip,
you mentioned your early lus
for Governor Cuomo.
How are you feeling now?
Because, you know,
the vaccine roll-out
is not crushing it.
-No, he's not crushing it.
I'm over him.
He's too old and sloppy
anyway for me.
-[ Laughs ]
-You know what I mean?
I mean, I'm just not...
Like, he had his day.
He apexed, and now
the apex is over.
-[ Laughs ]
-Did you think --
Did he have a pretty good run,
as far as holding
Chelsea Handler's affection?
I feel like we're
being hard on him now,
but you had like four or fiv
months, right?
-Yeah.
No, he was definitely --
I mean, we were all
hot for it,
because we were all
so dehydrated
for decent leadership.
It's like, "Can somebody
be in charge around here?"
Like, just being in Canada
everybody's so different.
Everybody wears a mask.
Nobody's saying no
to wearing a mask.
You know, it's
so civilized here.
So I'm -- I forget
what the question --
Oh, Andrew Cuomo. Sorry.
I went off about my --
-That's how fast
he's left your mind.
-[ Laughs ]
-Couldn't even remember
his name.
[ Laughs ]
-I'm like, "Andrew who?"
First of all, I didn't even --
Let's be honest.
I didn't know
that Andrew Cuomo --
I thought Mario Cuomo
was the governor of New York
until COVID hit.
[ Laughter ]
So I was confused.
-He was one of
the first casualties --
we lost Mario.
-[ Laughs ]
-Early.
-Yeah, we did lose Mario early
-I do want to ask you --
obviously, you've been skiing,
and you mentioned you're alone
You've talked about
having trouble with guides
over the years --
specifically, male guides.
Are you skiing alone
or with assistance?
-Yeah, in my special --
my HBO Max special, "Evolution,"
I talk a lot
about how I get turned on
when a man is in control of me
as many women do.
I like to pay somebody
to look after me.
These are injuries, obviously,
from my childhood.
But I'm aware of them,
and I also like
the transaction of paying
someone to say, "Okay,
you're my responsibility."
Right?
But then I slip up,
because sometimes
I get romantic
with these people.
And that doesn't end well,
so now I ski
with only female guides.
-[ Laughs ]
So you don't trust yourself.
It's a classic Mike Pence move
-It's a... [ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Exactly.
-You know, we're
being so hard on him,
and there he's got
the same problem as you do
-Oh, Mike Pence is the worst
We could get rid of --
-No, you two are the same.
[ Laughter ]
-Twinsies!
-[ Laughs ]
-Hey, congratulations
on the special.
I can't imagine it was eas
putting that together
during the times
we're living in.
It's always such a delight
to see you, Chelsea.
-Always. You too, Seth.
Say hi to your family for me
-Alright, I'll see you soon,
I hope.